[Music]
why not
seek to achieve radical equality which
means
true equality as we can understand it
among everybody
and then people will do different things
they'll produce things they'll
they'll go here they'll go there they'll
you know some people may prefer to live
in the country in a small house
some may prefer to be in an apartment
building in other words
equalize opportunity and then let's see
what happens not just opportunity
equalize the outcomes otherwise we all
have
equal well because then we all have
we're equal we all end up with the equal
capacity to live our lives
and the resources to do that and make
choices about our lives
that's what i mean by radical quality we
all have the same thing
so somebody else the president of rogers
uh
does not have uh the company rogers or
the president
t they do not have huge amounts
of uh uh i understand equality of
outcome right because does that mean
that there needs to be fifty percent
women in prison
because there's ninety percent well look
at the negative note because that's
that's biasing by saying let's look at
the negative thing
because they should look at all we
should just look at the positives and
say hey there's but why not ten percent
but we don't we don't
we don't aim to do that that's something
we try to eradicate so we just say no
let's get get rid of that the the male
population let's undo
the incarceration system that is
you know incarcerating males or high
numbers and as females too let's not
ignore
female but that's that you know let's
figure out how to deal with the prison
population that has been mushrooming
in north america especially in the u.s
right equalizing outcome so how do we
draw the line
so we don't equalize outcome across the
board we equalize it only in the good
areas and then the negatives can affect
yes yes of course we seek to do that's
what society gives us
the ability to to seek after the good
outcome how do we achieve all the good
outcomes why would you want to seek
equality of bad outcomes i mean why we
want to right i mean if someone has bad
health well okay
you've got bad health mine's good like
we better equalize now
i'll start drinking pepsi 15 times a day
and whatever
that's right that doesn't make sense
well that to me seems like it is
equality of outcome i'm trying to
both come to york university and start
off now as remember we were talking
before
that in fact uh no i'm bringing certain
resources less resources than you're
bringing
already so what do we do about that
right i came from a really bad school
i came from a poor neighborhood where
you know there was just
huge horrible factors that said to me i
shouldn't
be paying attention so i'm you know i
mean so
how do we address that oh let's start a
program for someone like that to really
help them
get up get a leg up so i can come closer
to your capacity
based on that that's getting to the
that's the quality of outcome right
you